should qualifying for sports
include what's in your shorts
and they're canceling hockey season and
wokism is the reason
a canadian university they have two of
them now
has scrapped its intramural ice hockey
program after an equity audit deemed it
wasn't inclusive and accessible enough
and it also discriminated against trans
women as each game has three periods
i don't get
it terrible
oh it just gets worse
officials at mount royal university who
hasn't done that
that the move
was based on several factors such as
sense of belonging participant behavior
who the program was built by with
without and for equipment requirements
skill requirements participant fees
ice time cost blah blah blah
yeah no hockey equipment and ice time is
expensive but there's something more to
this but this is why i only played nude
chess as a teen
which was dangerous because i tripped
and fell on the pieces many times tyrus
on purpose you know
that was a clumsy lad
but i'm sure administrators probably
don't want to show their face on campus
now much like this guy
but enough about enough about sports
let's talk about the boston marathon
that was a great joke i loved it
this is boston marathon not a sport no
so everybody's like we don't care greg
which
boston marathon will now allow runners
to enter as non-binary without having to
register in the men's or women's
divisions plus they will have their
choice of porta-potties
tough crowd today
that one cracked me up at the office
but a key point to the new rules
race organizers have chosen the women's
qualifying times as the non-binary
standard so does that mean the male to
female trans will have an edge in
qualifying
oh
who knows
but the race takes place in april which
should give lia thomas plenty of time to
train and shave her gonads
so
now they clap hey
oh my gosh this is a tough crowd tigers
tyler's okay
come on how can they do this to hockey
it's the only sport left that white
people have
and by white i actually mean canadian
yeah because uh brothers are playing in
nhl and you probably haven't watched in
a while but it's all good listen um
so one person who couldn't
skate and didn't save their their pell
grant to buy gear
complained
and they went to twitter and an entire
intramural project is gone intramural is
like volunteers it's like you're not
good enough to have a scholarship or
play for the school so they allow
activities it's basketball there's
hockey there's softball gymnast it's a
plethora of sports for you to find out
and they probably would even have naked
chests so there is something for
everyone to do so if you can't skate you
don't get to cancel hockey and oh all
the people who play hockey been playing
hockey their whole life yeah it's not a
sport you just pick up yeah but they
have other ones for that so again this
is what happens when the woke get on and
the schools get afraid of twitter they
need to realize there's a reason why
musk slowed his role when he heard and
he figured out there's about maybe 30
percent of its bonds
stop subscribing to this stuff and
listen unless you're from kenya you can
be non-binary cyber ai you're not
winning the marathon
[Laughter]
what if i identify as kenyan
you are going to bring shame to the
kenyans
what's wrong cat don't care how much
time do you have
but i mean you know what's interesting
they're banning they're they're saying
hockey isn't like is somehow like not
safe to people's emotions it's not okay
you're hurt by hockey though i grew up
canada adjacent yes okay hockey's a big
deal in michigan i'm one of like i have
two siblings both of them played ice
hockey my brother played ice hockey my
sister played ice hockey i have like
negative athletic ability like like i
can't i i'm so i'm a danger to myself
and others when i try
so i couldn't stay home alone so you
know what i did i had to go and i ran
the scoreboard
and you know what was it embarrassing
yes but it also made it a lot easier to
be embarrassed as an adult because my
threshold was higher um
so i'm glad that you know they didn't
cancel all the hockey just because i
couldn't hockey or as we called it hacky
interesting i didn't know they called
the act but it's so funny because i mean
you to find a full set of teeth you'd
have to get like how many players
together yeah right so i mean but that's
like you you're worried about emotions
and feelings and is there any way you
can tie this to the queen
that's a hard one i'm going to turn that
one down i'm setting all my family in
one go exactly i think this is all about
jealousy i think when it comes down to
it it's that people who are jealous
they're not good at sport have a lot of
power on twitter and other places i
can't skate to save my life it's twenty
thirty dollars for me to fall smack dab
on my face break my teeth have everyone
laugh at me doesn't mean i think hockey
should be shut down i couldn't wrestle
with tyrus doesn't mean i think
wrestling should be shut down oh i'd
like to see that though yeah
for enough money oh
but it's all just about power and
jealousy yeah you know it's interesting
though we can't shut down the shutdown
people's stuff because they don't
they're not good at anything so they can
go after the hockey players they can go
after writers they can go after actors
but you can't go after them because all
they're good at is
starting fires on twitter and attacking
women yeah who's who's going to be axed
out women yeah but here's the thing
maybe
the boston marathon is trying to get
ahead of the problem by saying like by
creating another another category so
there isn't a problem so you're telling
me we went from everybody gets a trophy
to everybody gets a penis
[Applause]
that's amazing no it's
you're just playing blue tonight
i told you it's the dirty outfit um it's
just but do you remember we were we were
telling this joke two weeks ago when we
were talking about student loan
forgiveness and i said i'm not worried
about tuition my son's six foot five
he's gonna get a women's basketball
scholarship right okay but think about
that
that night people were tweeting at us
how dare you you're mocking this but
that's exactly what's going on men are
running in the women's marathon my cat
is gonna win the westminster dog show in
five years
yeah
i
i am going to win the westminster dog
show
because i can i can run so fast on all
fours it's amazing and i'll be the
smartest dog there why can't i why can't
i identify as a dog i'm into it i think
it's great but this is the scam of the
whole thing especially when it comes
back to hockey okay
we don't care if it's the whitest the
blackest or anything in between we just
want the best think of the nba nba 73
black nfl 70 black major
major league baseball predominantly
white and latino but none of us [ __ ]
because we're there to watch the best
players if you're going to [ __ ] in an
nfl game you're going to [ __ ] because
it's 22 dollars a beer you know what i'm
saying you're not going to care because
there's a white guy bringing it or a
black guy bringing it that's all i'm
saying fair point
not according to them they were like
that jimmy
stick with the transgender very fickle
audience tonight have you noticed this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else